At this point there is no longer any doubt that the migration pact is a tailor
-made for the extreme right and when we thought that
nothing could surprise us anymore,
meloni arrives and demands 1 little more to criminalize rescue NGOs.
We have been listening to the narratives to dehumanize migrants for years.
..
I understand that this way it is much more tolerable to accept that they sink
in the Sea that they are returned to 1 or that Be torture meat in places like
Olivia That's right sir corners what they don't say is that all that suffering
is paid for with our money that we allocate more and more resources to militarize
and externalize borders and that all that WILL be armored In the New Pact they
hide that they have turned the procedure to request asylum into a no-deal maze
It is impossible to meet their requirements to access this right This is not
VA for those who come from outside this VA of 1 attack on the rights
system that gives meaning to Europe.